بالعوده الى الخبر العاجل الذي نوهنا عنه
بشان تلقي امير دوله قطر اتصالا هاتفيا من
الرئيس الامريكي تم خلاله استعراض
التطورات في غزه والاراضي الفلسطينيه تنضم
الينا من البيت الابيض مراسله الجزيره وجد
وقفي هل من معلومات اكثر حول فحوى هذا
الاتصال
وجد البيت الابيض جمال اصدر بيانا مقتضبا
وقال انه سيرسل او يصدر بيانا مفصلا في
وقت لاحق لكن في بيانه المقتضب اكد بان
هذا الاتصال جاء بهدف مناقشه احدث
التطورات في غزه واسرائيل وبانه من اجل
مناقشه صفقه اطلاق سراح جميع المحتجزين
بحسب البيت الابيض الموجودين لدى حماس هذا
ما ترغب اداره بايدن بحصوله وحقيقه هذا
الاتصال جمال ياتي في وقت مهم للغايه
تعتبر الاداره الامريكيه ان اطلاق سراح
المحتجزين هو احد اهم اولوياتها حاليا
ولهذا الغرض يوجد برات ماغيرك وهو المسؤول
عن ملف الشرق الاوسط في مجلس الامن القومي
هنا في البيت الابيض بريت ماغرك يقوم
بزيارات مكوكيه كان في اسرائيل كان في مصر
قبل نحو ثلاثه ايام انتقل الى الدوحه حتى
يوم امس كان في الدوحه وفق البيت الابيض
وايضا التوقيت هذا وهذا الاتصال ياتي في
الوقت الذي اعلن فيه البيت الابيض عن
ايفاد مدير الاستخبارات الامريكيه سي اي
اي ويليام بيرنز خلال الايام المقبله الى
المنطقه من اجل غرض ذاته وهي المساعده في
ضمان الحصول على اتفاق لاطلاق سراح
المحتجزين طبعا هذا الاتفاق هناك تسريبات
صحفيه تحدثت عن ان مدته نحو شهرين على ان
يتم اطلاق سراح جميع
المحتجزين ولكن حتى الان البيت الابيض لم
يؤكد اي من تلك المعلومات التي وردت في
وسائل اعلام امريكيه جمال فقط نضيف ايضا
بان هذا الاتصال ياتي بعد ايام قليله من
التسريب الصوتي لنتنياهو خلال حديثه مع
عدد من اهالي المحتجزين الاسرائيليين
والذي زعم فيه بان دور قطر يمثل مشكله في
مناقشات او مفاوضات اطلاق سراح ابنائهم
وهذا الامر طبعا اثار حفيظه د وه قطر ولكن
البيت الابيض كان حذرا جدا في تعليقه على
هذه القضيه ولكن يمكن القول بانه قلل من
اهميه هذا او او تصريحات نتنياهو نسمع
دائما من البيت الابيض عبارات شكر لدور
دوله قطر في الوساطه من اجل اطلاق سراح
الرهائن من اجل انت خال مساعدات انسانيه
وكلها قضايا انسانيه ولا ينفك البيت
الابيض عن اطلاق تصريحات فيها الكثير من
الشكر والثناء لهذا الدور لدوله قطر ايضا
هذا الاتصال لا يمكن ان نفصله توفي من
ناحيه توقيته جمال عن قرار محكمه العدل
العليا الذي امر اسرائيل بادخال المساعدات
وبتجنب ايقاع ضحايا في صفوف المدينين في
غزه وجد وقف مراصده الجزيره متحدثه من
البيت الابيض